anyway this [ __ ] got weed he got stem
please right here [ __ ] oh you really
made my day ain't like put that [ __ ] in
the pillowcase dawg
you knew you so you're gonna roll with
me now this is how this [ __ ] want to
talk me and I'm rollin with you know I
probably JA I don't hear that [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] put all this [ __ ] on [ __ ] I
figure out if I'm gonna give you
something up I'm not a [ __ ] cuz you
ain't getting [ __ ] right now [ __ ] put
all that ain't on me I mean you got some
nice colognes up here on the dresser man
and I know I'm gonna be wrong for taking
this from you man but lord knows I gotta
have all that don't put all that in the
bag
this [ __ ] started crying do i
straight-up start crying I'm like
looking at just what you don't man ain't
giving y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] you should have
just gave us a little paper look money
[ __ ] we would have been out of here
[ __ ] I'm taking all this [ __ ] and if
you get up and try and do something I'm
gonna kill your punk ass [ __ ] I split a
gun [ __ ] you better not get your [ __ ]
ass up [ __ ] i'ma kill you [ __ ] come on
[ __ ] bag it rest that [ __ ] up [ __ ] you
sit down over there
homeboy chill punk ass over there [ __ ]
that's what you [ __ ] gonna get [ __ ]
then next time a [ __ ] tell you our
[ __ ] asses the kickdown you're
gonna you're gonna kick down [ __ ] are
you gonna lose out more than what you
want [ __ ] and you might lose your life
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] especially you do
know got she did look I should just hit
you in the stomach with a bullet [ __ ]
just to show you ain't playin Punk
come on man get this [ __ ] [ __ ] let's go
make this punk-ass [ __ ] grow when he
spoke to be women but he supposed to be
with sneaking and turned into a spoon
damn true man I spent god I mean I hate
[ __ ] that's a collar man tell you don't
bring no gun on [ __ ] ass [ __ ] I think
we can get killed [ __ ] rollin in
another [ __ ] day would anyway if we
good
went back to my hood I kept mostly
everything though I think I gave that
[ __ ] like $50 dawg I kept everything
all the way everything CDs
socks Cologne I took [ __ ] clothes like
this man some nice outfit that [ __ ] ass
nice [ __ ] man ain't lie I can't help
myself man anyway that's enough tuff of
mine that's another tough side of my
life I'm changing though man for the
better man I'd only want people that you
know acknowledge the good side of me and
not the bad and I know that a person
can't change man you just had to want to
change
how'd you grow up I grew up man
in a neighborhood where when it was
gangs man and I mean you can wake up in
the morning get ready to go to school
body be laying in the trash can you be
like cuz once you even told your mother
one time shoot why I tell her the second
or the third time cuz they don't matter
no mo it's like just all this trash you
know so my family never really look at
it real you know we knew that we was in
a tough-ass area where you know they
didn't play games over here and I had to
fight man I did I grew up fighting
different dudes you know so I can be
that person that was acknowledged I had
to fight for my little brother and my
little brother had to fight put full of
young one under him and I had a older
brother which he had to fight for me
against other people and my bigger
brother had to fight man it was like a
train that's what and if you've seen
some of the peoples we fought in this
neighborhood may you be surprised my
sisters we didn't even know nothing
about gangster I'll just start off you
know and my sisters I remember one time
she had a blue a blue bandana over here
and a do snatched it off her head and I
burnt it I just looked at I was like
you're too young to really acknowledge
you know what happened why I did it and
I'm like that I really just didn't know
I don't think he just was mad at my
something just you know
with natural hair something you know you
never knew to do was you know about
colors and stuff and gradually as time
went on you know we would fight for for
turf and colors you wear red they wear
blue you know when she was into each
other I mean I was going to elementary
getting high smoking on weed and [ __ ]
like that
you know drinking and then grazia I
started selling PCP I bought me some I
bought me some powder cocaine I started
smoking powder cocaine man and it was
tough man because I thought it was just
I thought it was cool man putting that
[ __ ] in and my all on my gums and [ __ ]
you know putting him in cigarettes you
know we called him tc's you know you
know as you've seen time you know turn
over and turn over because I was smoking
powder cocaine fly with to jail I did a
robbery
did a little time there like three and a
half years and Youth Authority came out
up my head was like a big old vegetable
you know I thought I was bad as dude
that and I'm really squabble with
everybody let them know I'm here you
know but you can't run the neighborhood
you can be a part of the foundation but
you came running the neighborhood anyway
I started selling powder again now when
I get out they got rocks and DVDs real
you know real Street don't parents
certain parents that we're being you
know exposed to this type of drug
because it was it was your mama you
wouldn't want this homie of mine to be
selling your mother drugs so we were
trying to keep that real you know
limited on who you sell drugs to slowly
but surely it got out of hand then
people started being greedy and not
paying attention to the real
responsibilities and the things that was
more important I started doing the wrong
things disrespecting not respecting you
know other people's other parents
people's parents he was a lot of the
dudes in the neighborhood and the
females too you know they ignore the
right thing you know and they got bad
so they started selling the people's
mother now the parents is breaking down
in the house you got no foundation
really standing good everything starting
to crumble you wonder why the tears in
the man's eye because everything he
thought he was building good turn tennis
nut but does later on as you looked down
the road here you are using the same
thing that they was used
and trying to figure out how to get off
of it what did it take to leave it alone
how strong that you need to be in order
to stop man
Mars is bad my life is real tough I had
to deal with a lot of [ __ ] in the
street I got shot a few times I didn't
been beat with across the head with a
board [ __ ] Dan accused me of doing the
robbery in a spot and I ain't robbed
[ __ ] I didn't been told that I took this
from man and I ain't never even seen
this [ __ ] policing took me to
jail then Jam me with [ __ ] and then
you want to know how much sanity you can
hold man walk the light walk this road
straight black man ain't really got too
much you know coming in this world so I
mean really dull myself a cent I do
everything I can to fight this week and
this up off of me sometimes I feel like
a demon or something that's walking
behind me and it's touching me
but what you believe me if I told you
that or what you think I was just up
here [ __ ] I don't have no reason to
[ __ ]
I can [ __ ] myself down the road I
got a lot of people's I could just talk
to him on the sideline I'd rather give
it to you straight so you ain't gotta
talk about it no boat and just know that
it was it something that existed a
[ __ ] living this life out here
dawg and it's tough and it's real and
it's weary when I say that look behind
you God down me and wonder what the [ __ ]
just touched you cuz it wasn't me
give your dad my pops god when I was kid
man I never really experienced the
father me and my brothers you know we
used to deal with my mother's boyfriend
but we didn't allow stepdaddy's in the
house too tough man you know we knew
that mom needed to get herself you know
need to get our rocks off we didn't
really know a whole bunch about that but
we know that something in there that she
needed to do so we gave that respect to
it but stepdance my brother's man they
they beat the stepdaddy's up so we never
one time my brother told me he say
let me come let me in I was like dog
doo-doo downstairs man [ __ ] come let
me in man this [ __ ] something else man
I'll go down and let you hear he and my
mother's boyfriend fight he'd knocked in
the guy I don't even know the [ __ ]
knocked out man I thought he was dead
I said oh man he said as we get to leg
Rand ankle is leg [ __ ] what the man we
drug this dude and put him on somebody
porch over there and set him up like he
was sleeping and I was saying [ __ ] Lee
she look alright dog [ __ ] from that way
[ __ ] I went on back in the house dude I
kept looking out the window to see if he
was all right that's mean I know he was
gone I was like [ __ ] oh man you know
from there it got real bad because I
said I know this new gonna call my
mother War William so I'm trove Oh
Dwayne and bigger so I figured she was
been first you know I can get a chance
to get a break because she like him a
long time he big and stuff so my brother
he was like all yoked up and sure I
might [ __ ] she won't move him a long
time she she gonna buy ourselves out
with him [ __ ] so I might get a little
break so I said mama Dwayne told me
though I didn't really do nothing could
keep me like wait just wait boy I'm
gonna tell you about what let me talk to
her
mostly they're saying war is gonna be
tough on me man yeah if you say huh
and he did what oh no what you did up in
that what happened I think you know run
away [ __ ] I ain't gonna sit with this
one I'm gonna just get up out of here
you know she says think of it I say
uh-huh we're doing that I mean it eat it
eat upstairs I think
marsinah going to rule me or anything
she looking for the caller worse his
name was with there's a stingy card man
I'm looking at oh I got to get out of
here I'm sitting right away it's tough
now that's why I say her boyfriends I
won't be willing to mess with them
[ __ ] you know Wayne did that boy and
then one last time though I remember I
took my mother's boyfriend his key I
jumped in the [ __ ] Cadillac I'll say
[ __ ] this one clue that's all I was
trying to draw on the Cadillac like you
know you see people you know driving
with no hands and [ __ ] and I let this
stand we'll go
and then one from and I caught my move I
couldn't catch it all man and my [ __ ]
rat on you know oh man I'm really in
trouble now only you know how to tell
Leroy I wrecked that car man oh man I
left the keys oh I'm just gonna say
somebody broke in her heart oh no I was
I was upstairs no nothing
oh no [ __ ] what month a UH John Cena
Stone key uh-huh
he's gonna go to school by one all right
boy I'll see y'all
I got up out of there but when he seen
me later
he said boy if I catch you one of you
[ __ ] almost touching my mother will
kill you [ __ ] I said ma'am don't mess
with your stuff man she did one of my
old boyfriends gave me then he got your
stuff she you need to be checking them
uh-huh
I bet you with your ass ain't never
gonna jump in yo car [ __ ]
don't I mean I had some cool toys man I
had some bad times ran because the wrong
I was doing man
I met one time one time I had a little
22 man it was two white dudes first time
I've ever seen this man - why - I
thought it was the police don't be
honest they pulled in the parking lot I
look down I say what's up buddy what I
want
they said I was in here I say y'all cops
you know believe me another I walked in
the car and I said what y'all trying to
buy y'all trying to buy some drugs or
something we know y'all cops they say
he's got God and I said you not they got
out the car man he got this neighborhood
I live in snubber blacks at the time man
just doing the seventies snubber blacks
right here dawg
and they got out the car and I pointed
the gun at him I'll say Malik to kill
y'all [ __ ] ass [ __ ] y'all doing
and then he did the gun like this man he
just puts the gun straight up others out
of the out of the face of it know what
[ __ ] you doing
you killed you do
putting no hands on my gun figure out
some crazy white boys man I don't see no
woods come over here like that man
yelling huh yawning cups and they wasn't
cause we actually didn't even [ __ ] with
him after that they didn't show no fear
like they was cool we were all just said
[ __ ] and left him he just got on I I
was surprised because I've never had a
guy take the you know smack the gun out
of this out of his face
you know but you know I would eat boom
you know but I wasn't anxious to really
shoot him because it was early in the
morning but we was just thinking the
ponies are trying to do a little sneak
sneak in here but they wasn't caught and
I'm glad that they wasn't because see
buddy coulda took the gun and killed me
with the muffler but at first I was
saying - I do stay down like that and I
always remember that
you